tony stark may be gone but his genius
lives on through peter parker's suit
choices in spider-man no way home peter
sports an outstanding number of
spider-man suits throughout the film's
148-minute run time some of them are
fits fans have seen before and others
are brand new to the mcu here's a quick
rundown warning major spoilers ahead you
ready
i'm ready
no way home begins right where 2019
spider-man far from home left off
mysterio's doctored footage revealing
the true identity of spider-man is
released by the daily bugle now the
whole world is against peter parker and
believes him to be a murderer with this
turn of events it's only appropriate
that a connection between the two films
remains intact this connective tissue is
the very first suit we see spider-man
wear in no way home his upgraded
spider-man suit the outfit we see in the
first act of the movies is the same one
he creates on tony stark's plane in far
from home and proceeds to wear in his
final battle against mysterio it's nice
to see this earlier suit return
especially considering we've only seen
it in one previous fight for the most
part the oldest suit remains in peter's
closet throughout much of the run time
of no way home after the opening
sequence peter's in trouble with the law
so he doesn't do a ton of crime fighting
the suit featured most prominently in
the marketing materials for no way home
is the iron spider suit also known as
the iron spider armor this is what peter
parker wears during one of his battles
against dark ark the iron spider suit is
made up of nanotech enveloping peter
right when he needs protection and boy
does he need it against the duck at one
point during their fight the scientist
takes the blade out from one of his
tentacles right when it's about to peer
spider-man's exposed chest the
nanoparticles shift position from his
face to his chest protecting him from
the attack while revealing his identity
to the multiversal villain that's not
the only significant development
provided by the nanotech otto octavius
absorbs some of the particles into his
tentacles providing them with a red tint
featured throughout the trailers peter
is able to use this as his advantage and
since he has access to tony stark's tech
he's able to manipulate the tentacles to
do his bidding it ends the fight and
allows him to bring otto into doctor
strange's holding cell when the first
trailers for no way home were released
there was a lot of speculation about
what the black and gold suit would do
was it specifically designed with stand
attacks from electro as it turns out
it's simply peter parker's upgraded suit
turned inside out earlier in the film
with cp to get green paint thrown on him
plenty of new yorkers believe the daily
bugle's propaganda that he's responsible
for mysterio's death with no way to
prove his innocence beatrice puts up
with various assaults including being
dowsed with paint or wearing his
spiderman outfit he doesn't have time to
get it cleaned and always wanting to
look fresh he turns it inside out to
deal with the next interdimensional
threat as it turns out he looks pretty
slick in the new spider threads with the
prominent black fabric and gold accents
shortly after his battle with electro
peter gets the suit cleaned next up this
gold trim suit is one of the most highly
anticipated spidey suits fans have been
waiting to see in action the design was
initially teased as part of a toy league
for no way home and now that the movie's
house audiences can see what the so
called iron spider integration suit is
all about this shiny suit gives peter
the much needed boost in power he needs
to take on all of these previously seen
spider-man villains and surprisingly
it's actually in the movie for quite a
while the suit first makes an appearance
when spidey and friends are at happy
hogan's condo he then takes a suit with
him to the final battle at the statue of
liberty where he stands out compared to
the suits worn by andrew garfield and
toby maguire's spider-man yep garfield
and maguire both turn up and no way home
merry christmas true believers
exel
and finally no way home has what might
just be the most devastating ending of
any mcu film so far before more bad guys
can break into their universe peter
parker has dr strange perform a spell to
make the world forget that peter parker
exists
but still remember that there is a
spider-man as a result mj ned and happy
will lose all of their memories of him
it's a poignant moment and one that
exemplifies what the spider-man persona
is all about his entire philosophy
centers around sacrificing what he truly
wants for the betterment of the world
the last time we see peter he has his
own apartment and is studying for the
ged however he hasn't hung up his
spider-man suit just yet you may no
longer have access to all of tony's gear
but he's pretty proficient with a sewing
machine the last sequence sees him
jumping out of his apartment window
wearing a new homemade suit he designed
we can't show it here but he's stuck
with the red and blue palette from
previous costumes and it looks like
he'll be on his own in any future
franchise installments hey the title
wasn't lying when it said there was no
way home for peter
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
spider-man no way home are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]